this chapter the troubleshooter the story of
Bernard Baruch a mighty explosion took place in
July 1946 at bikini in the Pacific Ocean in that
mushrooming radioactive cloud the world faced a
magnificent promise and a dreadful threat the
plan for the worldwide control of atomic energy
must be adopted by the United Nations otherwise
the atom bomb might boomerang and destroy us all
the UN set up a commission to deal with the
problem the American delegate Bernard Baruch
he wrote and presented the American proposals a
vast responsibility but for Baruch great tasks
were an old story for decades he had been the
troubleshooter of presidents Baruch was born in
South Carolina five years after the Civil War as
a child he showed an uncanny knack for getting to
the heart of problems and solving them the family
moved to New York City in 1870 when the boy was 10
years old Barack's alma mater was the college
of the city of New York he was a good student
and so fine a boxer that he was advised to turn
professional but his southern
bred mother would not permit it
instead in 1890 he went to work in the New
York Stock Exchange Baruch learned quickly
earned the respect of his elders and became
a partner in the brokerage firm in those days
fortunes could be made or lost overnight
for Baruch it was the chance to become
wealthy he invested shrewdly in nineteen
five when he was 35 years old Baruch was
worth millions of dollars but mere wealth left
you dissatisfied you searched for a higher goal
in 1917 you found that goal service to your
country President Woodrow Wilson signed the
declaration that brought the United States
into the first world war from a goldfish
bowl were drawn the names of the first draft
teased an army of millions of men was being
formed they needed uniforms guns ships all the
implements of warfare there was great confusion
you were given the task of organizing
American industry for war production
you brought industrial confusion to a halt did
your job so well the Germany later confessed
that American production played a major part in
her defeat the peace conference at Versailles
you and Herbert Hoover were there with President
Wilson it was clear to you that Germany couldn't
pay the huge war reparations demanded by
Britain and France you urged the delegates
to take a more realistic approach for this you
were denounced by the Allies as pro-german with
President Wilson you returned to the United
States disillusioned but determined to fight
by Wilson's side for the League of Nations
the fight was doomed to failure in 1920 the
Republican Party swept back to power America
wanted to forget Europe Warren Harding became
president although a lifelong Democrat Baruch
advised the new President on economic matters
Bernard Baruch continued to give councils and
Economic Affairs when Calvin Coolidge became
president Herbert Hoover succeeded Coolidge as
the stock market climbed toward the sky no one
would listen to burr Oaks warnings of impending
disaster suddenly the country was plunged into
depression in the crisis Troubleshooters were
needed to find a way out men like Bernard Baruch
1932 the Democratic Party convention Baruch and
Will Rogers were there burl felt a man strong
enough to lead the country out of depression was
Franklin Roosevelt he paid for several of FDR's
election campaign broadcasts next year baroque
was present at Roosevelt's inauguration let me
assert my firm belief that the only thing
we have to fear is fear itself the National
Recovery Act was launched with stirring big
city parades Farooq's close friend general
Hugh Johnson was director of the NRA farooq
himself as a member of Roosevelt's inner circle
when roosevelt's first cabinet assembled Beru
could have been among its members he had been
offered the post of Secretary of Treasury and
turned it down baroque didn't want public office
he wanted only the chance to be of service
without glamour of publicity then Franklin
Roosevelt took a step that temporarily disrupted
their friendship burr Luke disapproved several
of the president's early fiscal measures he was
out of favor and four years was rarely called at
the White House but with the Second World War
you went back into harness a troubleshooter
was needed to solve the grave robber shortage and
Roosevelt chose you for the job as assistants you
had James Conant of Harvard and Karl Compton of
Massachusetts Institute of Technology the problem
how to provide rubber for the Armed Forces and for
civilian needs out of America's small stockpile
you studied the problem and reported to the White
House with recommendations the recommendations
were approved and you reported to the people we
are recommending as the only means we have been
able to see nationwide gasoline rationing but
for the purpose of conserving tires not gas our
choice is to cut discomfort or defeat new tires
for army trucks and artillery born of worn-out
carcasses salvaged rubber synthetic rubber gas
rationing step by step the shortage was overcome
and back to the White House to undertake a new
assignment the manpower shortage looking into
the problem you found cause for grave concern
with war production booming and millions of men
in service competition for labor was fierce
you found the solution a manpower budget
the unnecessary hoarding of workers
by manufacturers with cost plus war
contracts should be eliminated employers should
be limited in the number of workers they could
hire and workers should be limited in their
choice of jobs labor should be funneled into
the war production industries where men were
needed desperately yet with a manpower budget
civilian production industries would not suffer
unduly there would be enough workers for all
that task finished you visited the war
France in 1944 General George Patton
gave you good news German resistance was
breaking they couldn't fight on much longer
but bad news when you returned home Franklin
Roosevelt had reached a limit of his strength
the commander-in-chief passed away in April
1945 a few weeks before Germany surrendered
it was a staggering loss to the nation
and a tremendous personal loss to you
in spite of disagreements you had admired
Franklin Roosevelt he'd been a great leader
Harry Truman stepped into the vacant place
and sent a plane on a mission that would
change the course of mankind's destiny
the bombers target was the Japanese city
of Hiroshima or better or worse men had
unleashed a frightful power of the atom
Pandora's box was open the mushrooming cloud
assured in the age of atomic energy what the
bomb could do was written plain in the
city below death and desolation a city
transformed into a heap of radioactive rubble
it happened once again before Japan surrendered
now a new White House assignment for Bernard
Baruch to present America's atomic energy
control plan to the United Nations he called
for an international authority with powers
of inspection and Swift punishment for
violators of the agreement the Russian
delegate Andrei Gromyko objected the plan he
said was not acceptable to the Soviet Union
when the showdown came the smaller nations
waver but in the final vote they stood with
the United States Russia would veto the plan
but the principles of atomic energy control
advanced by baruch had been established it was
the crowning achievement of his eventful life
1953 a new president was in the White House
Dwight Eisenhower and Baruch renewed an old
Association when Winston Churchill visited
the United States verruckt friendship with
Churchill dated back to the first world war
his friendship with Eisenhower began in the
second well past his 80th year Bernard Baruch
was still in harness he wanted it that way in
service to others he had found the secret of human
happiness he had given much of his wealth to aid
youngsters much of his strength to aid presidents
Bernard Baruch America's ace troubleshooter